autre voilà déjà trois ans que johnny
hallyday nous a quittés il était
certainement la dernière icône française
aussi populaire pas étonnant donc qu'il
soit aussi l'un des artistes les mieux
payés
[Musique]
c'est ce que révèle celui qui a été son
producteur durant des décennies invité
de non-stop by paul jean claude camus a
révélé le montant exorbitant qu'il a
réglés à la star pour l'une de ses
dernières tournées je crois que le
dernier échec que je fais à johnny et la
prescription datant pas d'hier c'était
19 millions un chèque de 19 millions
d'euros pour une seule tournée
si on sait que johnny détenait un
patrimoine de 40 millions d'euros dont
30 millions d'euros d'immobilier il est
difficile d'imaginer les sommes folles
qu'il a engrangés avec ses tournées
mythique et la vente de ces titres
alors êtes vous choqué par les
révélations autour de la fortune de
johnny hallyday johnny hallyday merci
fabien lecoeuvre nous a rejoint notre
fabien bien sûr son livre dictionnaire
officiel des chansons françaises ils
nous racontent toutes les chansons on
adore fabien qui nous raconte si bien
les histoires
alors johnny hallyday vous l'avez vu un
prêt de 20 millions d'euros et est ce
que c'est vrai cette affaire évidemment
sans doute une fois la parole du
producteur historique qu'est jean claude
camus un moment donné c'est impossible
johnny entre entre on va dire le 16
avril 1960 et le 5 juillet mais 2010 est
la dernière fois qu'il monte sur scène
là comme chantait 3257 fois en concert
ah ouais c'est énorme carrière de 57 ans
et demi était gagné 1,5 million d'euros
par an de droits d'auteur maintenant oui
mais c'est pas beaucoup par goldman on
n'en sait rien parce qu'en fait johnny
est intervenu sur les musées rien sur
les 1350 chansons qu'il a interprétées
réellement il en a une centaine qu'il a
co composés ou co écrite avec le
parolier ou un compositeur syrien y
dépenser sans compter
ça j'avais cela je te dis ça coûte une
tendance
elle savait si les droits d'auteur non
mais ouais il était il dépense est par
contre plus vite que son nom c'est à
dire que un jour en 2006 par exemple il
est allé au canada à faire une tournée
triomphale évidemment lâche-t-elle
canada non il a acheté comme ça il est
allé déjeuner il a trouvé une maison
très sympa il a acheté 500 hectares très
bien il a signé une promesse très bien
quand il a dit laeticia j'ai acheté un
ranch elle voulait pas aller au canada
on est en 2006 1 donc les avocats sont
rentrés en piste heureusement il avait
pas versé d'argent à paris à l'idée mais
non mais c'est quand même énorme
et puis un an ça lui a coûté 100 mille
dollars de dédit ou pactes pour annuler
cette province est à dire qui mais
diffusait des trucs d'acheter des motos
des harley davidson des pâtes et des
voitures somptueuses non à gagner
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent il le dépense
est énormément fait des révélations dont
20 millions d'euros sur le dernier
chèque qu'il a fait ouais
johnny durée c'était quoi le sait quoi
vraiment le patrimoine de johnny ce qui
passe il reste de la fortune de benoît
c'est beaucoup d'argent parce qu'il ya
les revenus t1 qu'il faut savoir faut
expliquer un chanteur gagne sur les
ventes de disques mais c'est très
important en tant qu'interprète après
auteur compositeur c'était moyen chez
lui parce qu'il n'était pas vraiment
hauteur de ses chansons du compositeur
pas plus que ça il était par contre un
peu éditeurs notamment sur la 2e 3e
partie de sa carrière
et puis le merchandising on a oublié ce
détail qui est essentielle johnny dans
les concerts de johnny tous ceux qui ont
aidé dans ses concerts ont bien vu tout
ce qu'ils vendaient les mugs les
briquets on parle de 40 millions d'euros
2 je pense que c'est ça qui savait pas
beaucoup mais c'est sûr numéro alors si
je suis d'accord mais c'est quand même
ça a été le chanteur numéro un pendant
des années ne sont pas une somme non
c'est le seul qui remplissaient les
staffs zone énorme et s'est passé quand
même s'est passé comme un sportif voilà
je sais que paris aurait ces lignes on
est là près de 2 500 millions d'euros de
fortune à la serbie un truc à las vegas
jean claude camus dit que coullier
finalement euros dupont jean claude
camus dit que johnny en caisse
on va dire aller 19 millions un chèque
sur une tournée une tournée c'est 50
dates
ouais johnny fait 187 tourner dans sa
carrière je vous laisse imaginer ça
représente à peu près 350 mille euros
par date
d'accord un chanteur de la trempe de
johnny c'est pas énorme
c'est ça le regarde et les salaires de
mick jagger de mac
un air de bowie de youtou même kurt
cobain aux états unis enfin c'était des
sommes mais les autres aujourd'hui que
mondial non mais et c'est mondiale bien
sûr mais ce que je comprends pas c'est
pourquoi on ne dit pas en fait que nous
pardon dire ça tout est relatif par
rapport à des gens qui nous vient mais
pour ce qu'il était et est le phénomène
qui est encore assez d'éléments exemple
quasiment pauvres parce qu il a fait
gagner beaucoup d'argent et je sais je
sais qu'il a il a enfin saint barth il
avait un rythme de vie incroyable puis à
l'heure il dépenser l'argent déjà ça de
gagné 50 et alors il a toujours été
entourée d'hommes d'affaires important
que ce soit johnny star que ce soit
gilles paquet que ce soit jean claude
camus que ce soit mais mme kooli un
monde dans sa vie aussi
françois boudou le beau père le père
laetitia c'est des gens qui intervenait
à un moment donné souvent pascal [ __ ]
n'a oublié aussi qui a été très
important dans la carrière de johnny
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné il eut
versé des avances d avance il négocie
auprès des banques pour retoucher de
l'argent et l emprunter de l'argent à sa
maison de disques et aux bons à bah oui
quand il a acheté la laura d'asselah
pratiquement universelle qui a payé la
lorada ou des pays et pour son soutien
ils avaient adopté une nouvelle
technique c'était quoi quand son système
audio ni parce qu'il emprunte à tout le
monde il emprunté quoi il demande était
confiant sur l'avenir
il est très confiant c'est à dire qu'en
fait ils savaient que ico y avait
conscience de ce qu'il était devenu en
france évidemment au nahd est un
chanteur c'est devenu un monument
donc ils savent ils ce avec toute façon
ils génèrent générerait de l'argent et
puis fréquentait beaucoup de gens autour
de lui qui avait beaucoup d'argent aussi
donc il utilisait un peu tous ses
réseaux ses relations il a 40 millions
de patrimoine way dont 30 millions
d'euros d'immobilier et 30 millions de
dettes non mais et puis on a oublié un
9-0 moines en personne n'en parle
c'est les motos les voitures et que ça
parce que c'est des voitures à 160000
euros la voiture c'est des motos à 75000
euros
mais il ya quand il ya un parking avec
75 voitures et 35 moto ça fait vite de
l'argent aussi